so we've just watched a short video
about Watson which I always associated
with with jeopardy as I imagine most of
us do so so talk to us dr. Chaudry a
little bit about what Watson's role
might be in the doctor's office it's a
great question i think you know jeopardy
presented as an additional set of
challenges and i think we're gonna eager
to adapt the technology to different
industries to create solutions that
we're going to have meaningful value to
people and what they're hoping to
accomplish I think with health care has
been one on ones we've prioritized and I
think you know what we roughly see
Watson doing is helping people deal with
the cognitive burden of healthcare and
medicine and what do I mean by that I
think the experience of getting health
care for patients and consumers is often
overwhelming the experience of doing it
as a physician is often overwhelming to
provide I think even sub sub specialists
in their field for instance can't really
keep up with all the things they need to
read just to practice medicine you know
the best way that they can so we
envision Watson as a model for cognitive
computing where it's providing support
to people for the different kinds of
reasoning tasks that they have to engage
in to accomplish their work efficiently